[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Gérard Larcher président
du Sénat qui va clôturer notre
matinée il est en
forme bien cher Nicolas Sarkozy qui est
en forme là et mes chers amis c'est le
début je d'abord moi aussi remercier
tous ceux qui ont animé cette matinée et
que je me réjouis que nous ayons
retrouvé le goût du débat y compris
quand il est
vivant nous sommes parvenus à définir un
socle de valeur et je veux remercier
Nicolas Sarkozy pour cet exercice réussi
et qui ne clot pas le temps des
propositions qui doivent s'adresser à
tous les Français c'est un point que
nous avons à partage à la fin de l'été
la campagne des
primaires commencera et chaque candidat
développera son projet dé livrera ses
orientations ce sera l'heure des
échanges puis du choix mais je sais
aussi que le débat qui s'engagera se
fera partir de ce que nous avons en
commun et qui nous rassemble puis il y
aura le temps du vote et nous nous
retrouverons tous rassemblés le 27 au
soir et je le dis
clairement personne ne peut s'exclure de
respecter la règle que nous nous sommes
fixés collectivement
mais le plus accompli fut-il des projets
ne peut exister sans l'affirmation
préalable de notre attachement à un état
puissant source d'autorité
cafouillage sur NotreDame des Landes
dérapage sur cvin paralysie à calé
impunité des casseurs
ordre et contre-ordre sur les interdits
ition de
manifestation nuit debout et les scènes
de guerriat urbaine le délitement de
l'autorité de l'État depuis plus de 4
ans maintenant conduit au sentiment
partagés par nos compatriotes d'un
désordre installé dans notre pays cette
perte d'autorité de l'État est devenue
insupportable à la France et aux
Français plus de 70 % d'entre eux
estiment dans une analyse récente que
tel est le cas pour la France cette
perte d'autorité mine sa
crédibilité comment prétendre jouer le
jeu des grands sur la scène
internationale quand la presse étrangère
titre sur l'impuissance d'un état
incapable de faire cesser la pagaille
qui règne au moment où il organise un
événement sportif de portée médiatique
internationale ou quand le New York
Times met à sa Une la photo de CRS
confronté à des manifest
comment lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme et assurer la sécurité des
Français quand nos forces de l'ordre
sont mobilisé pour s'occuper de la
chanlie en plein cœur de Paris de Renn
ou de Nantes la France si elle laisse
saper les fondements de son autorité
resque de risque de perdre la maîtrise
des territoires nul besoin de remonter
loin dans l'histoire pour en apercevoir
le spectre les territoires perdu de la
République ou les zones de non droit ou
voyou ou salafiste et c'est parfois les
mêmes règnent en maître devant une
population
désabusée pour les Français la perte de
confiance en l'autorité de l'État et
synonyme d'anxiété quand on TR pour sa
sécurité ou celle de ses enfants on est
ni libre ni heureux et je suis blessé
quand certains de nos compatriotes
finissent par choisir le chemin de
l'exil alors qu'ils appartiennent à la
communauté nationale nous parti des
républicains avons le devoir de
restaurer l'autorité de l'état car si
les populisme se nourrisse du désordre
c'est l'état de droit qui protège la
démocratie et les citoyens les
populistes confondent avec perfidie
autorité de l'État et État autoritaire
pour restaurer cette autorité je vois
pour ma part quatre urgences en tout
premier lieu la fonction
présidentielle notre président entre
guillemets normal s'est rapidement
transformé en anomalie pour la fonction
qu'il devait
incarner or la 5è République a été
conçue pour être représenté par un homme
ou une femme solide le chef des armées
garant de la continuité de l'État et
surtout arbitre entre les pouvoirs
j'étais avec les sénateurs Gaulistes à
baayeux les 10 et 11 juin dernier pour
réfléchir ensemble 70 ans après au
discours fondateur du général de Gaulle
c'est abailleux qu'il avait fait le
choix d'un président de la République
placé au-dessus des partis qui soit
garant de l'intérêt général avec un
gouvernement qui gouverne et un
parlement bicaméral qui exerce avec
rigueur sa mission législative et de
contrôle il avait souhaité donner à la
France une constitution forte et s'était
prononcé en faveur des mêmes
institutions qui devaient être fortes
seul capable de réformer notre pays et
d'affronter les crises alors à ceux qui
par ignorance ou par calcul voudrait
ébranler cet édifice je dis mesurer
toutes les responsabilité qu'il y aurait
abradé ce qu'il y a de plus solide dans
nos institutions le président qui sera
élu en 2017 devra donc d'abord
réhabiliter la fonction présidentielle
et l'exercer
pleinement c'est
l'inclassable c'est l'inclassable
médecin sociologue Gustave Lebon qui
écrivait la s autorité est aussi
impuissante que l'autorité sans
compétence le président de la République
doit donc s'appuyer sur des forces de
sécurité et une justice en capacité de
faire respecter l'État de droit c'est me
semble-t-il la seconde urgence un État
fort c'est une police et une gendarmerie
guidé guidé par des objectifs clairs et
soutenus par une volonté politique un
État fort est un état qui fait respecter
partout les lois de la République et qui
s'oppose à tous les communautarismes qui
s'attaquent à nos valeurs nous avons
trop longtemps renoncé collectivement
renoncer et tolérer une radicalité qui a
rusé avec notre droit et refusé d'entrer
dans notre histoire et quand l'autorité
de l'État vacille alors c'est la
radicalité qui s'impose il faut
maintenant que l'islam modéré qui
respecte la République et ses règles
nous l'aidions sur ce chemin nous devons
retrouver un état
qui se porte garant de la cohésion
nationale et non à ferment de division
et de fragmentation sociale religieuse
ethnique ou territoriale un État fort
c'est aussi un état qui a les moyens de
faire respecter la loi or le service
public de la justice est en péril
comment tolérer que les prévenus soient
relâchés avant leur comparition devant
le juges faute de pouvoir les
transporter du centre de détention au
tribunal c'est ça la réalité
quotidienne l'autorité de l'État devra
enfin s'imposer cher Christian
Saint-Étienne pour remettre de l'ordre
dans nos finances publiques cette trè
urgence est
essentielle car à tous les
souverainistes je dis quelle est la
condition première d'une véritable
souveraineté il nous faudra maîtriser
notre dette donner plus de liberté à nos
entreprises par plus de flexibilité pour
plus de croissance et plus d'emploi tout
en étant attentif à l'obligation de
réinventer un dialogue social du 21e
siècle indispensable à notre cohésion
sociale enfin le prochain Président de
la République devra faire preuve
d'autorité pour réduire la fracture
territoriale que connaît notre pays une
France que j'ai appelé dans un rapport
au président de la République il y a un
peu plus d'un an la France d'un côté
celle qui souffre en silence c'est celle
des villages des petites villes de
bourcentre parfois de certains quartiers
ou périphéries de nos villes qui sont
aujourd'hui encore plus démunis encore
plus dépourvus de service public que
bien d'autres territoires il nous faudra
redonner espoir à cette France là cette
France négligée qui a le sentiment
d'être abandonné quand elle n'a pas le
sentiment d'être méprisé et qui se jette
dans les bras des populisme alors mes
chers amis l'histoire de France nous en
avons un récit il faut maintenant
dessiner l'avenir une fois son autorité
restaurée notre pays fera de nouveau
raisonner puissamment sa voix en Europe
et dans le monde au service des valeurs
dont nous avons à faire fructifier
l'héritage l'Europe cela a été dit ce
matin traverse une crise parmi les plus
graves de son histoire depuis la guerre
froide il s'agit pas d'être pour ou
contre l'Europe la France est en Europe
et cher Philippe on ne peut pas être le
contre le continent auquel on
appartient il s'agit de savoir ce qu'on
veut faire de l'Europe l'Europe que nous
voulons signifie projet dynamisme
ambition partagé dans laquelle
d'ailleurs les parlements nationaux
doivent retrouver toute leur place le
futur président de la République devra
faire cesser cette guerre entre
guillemets inutile entre fédéraliste et
souverainiste et rassembler autour d'un
seul objectif relancer le projet EUR
pour assurer la survie et le renouveau
de la formidable idée européenne née
après la deuxème guerre mondiale être
goliste et nous le sommes désormais tous
un peu c'est croire que la nation
française constitue un héritage à
partager qui nous appartient de faire
vivre de transmettre au travers de notre
récit national de nouveau enseigner seul
la volonté et le courage politique nous
permettront d'y parvenir
et de redonner ainsi espoir à des
millions de
Français chers Nicolas chers amis ce
quinquena restera dans l'histoire comme
un quinquena pour
rien la situation de la France est
aggravée ce gouvernement aura inventé l'
ver d'ose fiscale aucune réforme
susceptible de remettre notre pays sur
la voie du redressement de la croissance
et de l'emploi n'a été réalisé on a au
contraire détruit détruit partie de ce
qui fait notre SOC parmi lesquels la
fierté de notre histoire mais aussi les
valeurs familiales alors la voix de la
France ne porte plus sur la scène
internationale et jamais notre société
n'a été autant
fracturée divisée et j'allais dire égaré
nous sommes maintenant au crépuscule de
ce quinquena il est grand temps d'écrire
une nouvelle page de notre histoire et
c'est à nous avec nos familles du centre
des républiques avec tous les Français
c'est à nous en rassemblant les Français
de le faire c'est notre responsabilité
pour que vive une France dont nous
sommes
fiers